health gets intriguing and the the
initially it seems like when they first
launched it they turned off a lot of
functionality didn't even ship with the
first software that came with the new
phones but now it's going on gangbusters
especially with the phone rolling out
you're gonna start to see more
applications for the water filling up
watch coming out last week you're going
to start to see more applications going
forward it's all part of Tim Cook's
strategy to put more of your digital
information into the Apple sphere and
you talk to investors and you talk to
other folks in the the wearable industry
and they see great potential here
because how much would you pay to live a
little bit longer that's kind of the the
idea behind improving health improving
fitness that these devices kind of
promise in Cedar sinai an enormous
organization how does this work on the
senior side or they're gonna hand out
iPhone solar patients well no this is
you're doing your online medical records
that you have access through through
their portal and they've just turned it
on so you can connect it through your
Apple device they're not quite sure
exactly how how patients are going to
react they just wanted to open up and
see what would happen let doctors have
that information to communicate with
their patients and see what goes forward
you know I mean I use the the jawbone up
to monitor my sleep and my exercise my
running and whatever else and I find
just just looking at it indeed there
have been studies when people look at
their food or even take pictures of
their food they eat better because in
you know Socrates said an unexamined
life is not worth living perhaps an
examined life is longer lived there's at
the basic notion here right I mean you
listen to Tim Cook earlier this year
talking about the beauty of the watch
and the health information that's being
collected it's it's a way to fight
cancer in some ways
yeah and Tim Cook himself quite a health
geek I mean is this a notion of apples
business model or it's an extension of
the CEOs notion of what people like just
like the last CEOs notion of what people
like it's definitely get something the
idea of your personal information this
ecosphere of Apple you look at Apple pay
their mobile payment system you look at
the entertainment information you look
at the photos you look at all these
things are trying to put into the world
of Apple so you become just a more loyal
customer going forward and and maybe
that's why we when we start to see the
notion of what this does for growing
their businesses isn't just about a neat
app to use with a phone but maybe grows
business and people are more locked into
that data
walked into the data but the arms also
the the billion dollar industry in the
healthcare industry and they they want
to be part of it
I guess if every if they're monitoring
every step every heartbeat your next
phone probably won't be a Samsung phone
if you want us if you want to stay with
sick of the program right